Ma allora io da qualche tempo non so
dire neanche bene perché mi occupo
scrivo leggo e parlo solo di cibo e in
questa mia attività
tendenzialmente faccio arrabbiare la
gente Questo è un po' quello che mi
succede quasi sempre
poco tempo fa mi è capitato ho detto che
la pizza probabilmente è più americana
che italiana mi hanno intasato la posta
elettronica con insulti minacce e tutto
quanto
questa cosa mi ha cominciato già da
tempo Anche prima era così però ho
cominciato a farmi pensare perché perché
noi siamo così sensibili a questa questo
aspetto della nostra cultura della
nostra identità perché noi italiani
siamo così suscettibili sulla questione
del cibo quando invece come vedete
Insomma diciamo l'inizio dell'Ottocento
il giudizio anche di uno come Goethe
chiamava l'Italia amava gli italiani era
L'Italia è bellissima L'unica cosa che
non devi fare è mangiare in Italia
perché comunque mangi male e la ho
cominciato quindi a chiedermi del perché
di questa di questa cosa ma D'altro
canto è anche strano perché se ci
pensate L'Italia ha dato al mondo anche
cose molto importanti molto recenti
pensiamo alla plastica la plastica la la
diventata Giulio Natta che ha preso il
Nobel per la chimica per questo pensiamo
il primo personal computer Mario ciù nel
1958 quindi noi abbiamo dato
l'informatica la plastica qualcosa che
davvero ha cambiato il mondo Però
effettivamente poi di queste cose ce ne
siamo dimenticati negli ultimi anni
invece continua a essere molto più
rilevante se ci va o non ci va la
cipolla nell'amatriciana se ci va la
panna nella carbonara insomma queste
sono i temi che in qualche modo ci
rendono abbastanza diciamo nervosi e se
ci metti la cipolla sai che stai facendo
una cosa che in qualche modo va a
minare La nostra identità oltre a fare
anche un peccato mortale perché questo è
evidente che se uno ci mette la cipolla
nell'amatriciana fa un peccato mortale e
allora io ho cominciato a chiedermi
perché in realtà ho cominciato ancora
prima a chiedermi questa cosa perché mi
è successo che nel 2018 quando la dieta
mediterranea è diventata patrimonio
dell'umanità
mi hanno invitato a Napoli hanno fatto
un grande convegno mi hanno invitato a
Napoli e veramente rimane strano del
perché abbiamo invitato me Comunque mi
hanno invitato per parlare e io ho
spiegato che gli italiani non hanno mai
mangiato seguendo la dieta mediterranea
Ovviamente si è scatenato il governo e
questa discussione è andata avanti
durante il coffee break che è andata
avanti In qualunque situazione e anche a
pranzo e anche nelle cene che c'erano a
margine del convegno a un certo punto
una collega americana mi ha detto Ma
perché voi italiani parlati di cibo
sempre parlate di cibo anche a tavola
che non ha assolutamente senso parlare
di cibo a tavola io lì per lì ho
cominciato a balbettare anche il mio
inglese non è un granché ho cominciato
balbettare delle risposte ma non sono
rimasto convinto nemmeno io stesso di
quello che dicevo allora ho cominciato
poi a pensare a questa cosa e da quel
momento Praticamente ci penso sempre e
la spiegazione che mi sono dato
e si porta un po' indietro si porta
esattamente al Boom economico l'Italia
dal 58-63 sostanzialmente ha fatto
quello che molti altri paesi hanno fatto
in 50 o 100 anni il boom economico son
qui cinque anni lì Poi è chiaro che la
crescita è proseguita anche negli anni
successivi ma il propriamente
quell'evento così esplosivo e la parola
Boom in qualche modo lo dimostra
è molto concentrata In quegli anni E in
quegli anni si è praticamente Travolta
ogni radice ogni identità anche
culturale storica che rappresentava la
nostra storia nel nostro paese e
Pasolini all'inizio degli anni 70 dice
la società dei consumi ha cambiato gli
italiani Lui parlava ovviamente in senso
anche negativo parlava dal punto di
vista antropologico diceva gli italiani
non sono più gli stessi È chiaro che lui
ne parlava anche in termini negativi
fondamentalmente Pasolini non
conservatore e però per gli italiani
questa cosa è assolutamente irrilevante
Tant'è vero che insomma lo scambio era
molto vantaggioso gli italiani sono
passati dalla fame dalla fame quella
nera quella brutta Ha un benessere che
non aveva nemmeno mai sognato prima
quindi alla fine va bene che denunciamo
le nostre radici se le nostre radici
sono quelle degli emigranti sono quelle
di chi per fame se ne deve andare via
tutto sommato non è una cosa di perdita
e in cambio abbiamo un grande benessere
Però proprio negli anni 70 succede una
serie di altre cose che mettono in
discussione tutto questo processo negli
anni 70 intanto l'illusione di una
crescita continua si interrompe gli anni
70 sono un decennio difficile per
l'economia del mondo per tanti motivi
per l'Italia in particolare comincia con
'68 con la contestazione poi c'è
l'inflazione 71 c'era la crisi del
dollaro nel 73 c'è la crisi petrolifera
nel 76 una cosa che non ci siamo che non
ci ricordiamo spesso ma nel 76 c'è il
disastro di Seveso quindi cominciamo
anche a fare i conti con i costi di
quella crescita industriale di quella
crescita economica che aveva regalato il
benessere di tagliare non tanto ce lo
siamo conquistati però aveva dato aveva
cambiato la vita degli italiani e
c'erano dei costi perché come sapete non
esistono pasti gratis e allora A quel
punto ho cominciato a esserci un po' di
dubbi la competizione internazionale
cominciava a essere difficile e
bisognava fare dei sacrifici bisogna
fare degli investimenti bisogna cambiare
un po' di cose e soprattutto comincia
anche la Glob situazione questa cosa per
cui tutto è facilmente delocalizzabile e
allora L'Italia ha tolto la ragione ha
cominciato a pensare che c'era almeno
una risorsa che non poteva essere
delocalizzata ed è la nostra storia la
nostra millenaria storia in fin dei
conti Le grandi cose che hanno
caratterizzato la nostra civiltà sono
iniziate qui Pensate ai Romani il
diritto la civiltà e la nostra
letteratura le nostre città le nostre
città splendide che nascono nel Medioevo
e che proseguono per tutte il
Rinascimento sono assolutamente come
dire patrimonio non delocalizzabile ed è
stato facile anche collegare poi tutto
questo alla cucina in fin dei conti le
nostre città sono effettivamente
splendide ed era anche facile immaginare
che fin dal Medioevo si mangiasse
benissimo in Italia nelle nostre città
nel Medioevo eravamo la più grande
economia la più grande civiltà Beh
ovviamente non è così in realtà gli
italiani per molto tempo hanno mangiato
poco e male
in Italia ha avuto anche adesso si parla
di sovranità Nazionale sovranità
alimentare ha avuto neanche nel
Settecento nell'800 sovranità alimentare
Ma quando è la sovranità alimentare
quando la nostra bilancia commerciale
dal punto di vista agricolo è inattivo
lo è da non perché esportavamo come
facciamo adesso un parmigiano cose
buonissime Ma perché esportavamo Setta
in realtà l'Italia
mangiavano gli italiani mangiavano
pochissimo mangiavano sempre le solite
cose a nord si mangiava la polenta uno
su tre ci aveva la pellagra a sud si
mangiava quello che si trovava E molto
spesso era vigeva la denutrizione nel
sud quindi c'era anche questa ulteriore
problema Quindi in realtà gli italiani
Appunto non è non è assolutamente vero
questa questa cosa per cui
gli italiani hanno sempre mangiato bene
c'è questa millenaria identità
alimentare però è successo ed è successo
negli ultimi decenni che a queste storie
a queste leggende che si collegano la
nostra grande storia la nostra cucina e
abbiamo cominciato a crederci Anche noi
abbiamo cominciato a dire sì ce lo
diciamo l'amatriciana si fa da sé la
carbonara la carbonara l'hanno fatta i
carbonari nel 500 che ovviamente non è
assolutamente vero E queste storie qui
stanno alla fine Guardate che ci rendono
anche ridicoli perché non so se vi
ricordate a gennaio 2021 quando il
governo italiano si è rifiutato di
spedire 250 mila dosi di vaccino
all'australia il governo australiano per
vendicarsi a mostrato un filmato dove
c'erano un ragazzo che spezzava gli
spaghetti faceva la carbonara ci metteva
la panna e diceva la chiameremo
carbonara fino a quando non ci manderete
i vaccini davvero siamo ridicoli da
questo punto di vista però il tema è
perché siamo diventati così cioè Cos'è
questa cosa cos'è quella quell'elemento
che in qualche modo ci rende così
particolare e guardate
questa cosa che noi facciamo per
identità in realtà fa del male perché
quello che stiamo facendo è quello di
mettere in freezer La nostra identità la
nostra tradizione che è la cosa peggiore
che possiamo fare perché la cucina in
realtà è sempre contaminazione e sempre
in costante cambiamento Quando io ho
iniziato parlando del fatto che a Napoli
si sono arrabbiati Quando io ho detto
che la pizza fosse più americana che
italiana guardate C'è un andato di fatto
la pizza è sicuramente nata a Napoli ma
se noi oggi mangiassimo la pizza che
mangiavano a Napoli nell'Ottocento come
minimo saremmo molto delusi e faremo
molta fatica a esportarla nel mondo e
farebbero molto fatica anche i pizzaioli
napoletani a vendere la loro pizza ai
napoletani perché ci sono tante
testimonianze sulla pizza napoletana
tantissime Anche dal punto di vista
letterario ne ho tirate fuori qualcuno
perché su tutto le definizioni sono
sempre abbastanza diverse difficili ma
c'è un dato sul quale sono tutti diciamo
d'accordo
La pizza è una grandissima schifezza
Guardate cosa dicono cosa diceva
nel 1843 le pizze possono sostituire
vantaggiosamente se non gradevolmente la
galletta di bordo poi di una va avanti e
dice che in fondo è contro la pizza si
può mangiare anche dopo sette giorni
Provate a mangiare una pizza dopo sette
giorni Poi mi dite cosa state mangiando
Ecco quindi questo è quello che dice di
ma nel 1843 Ma la cosa peggiore la dice
Collodi
dice e vuoi sapere cos'è la pizza è una
schiacciata di pasta di pane lievitato
abbrustolita in forno ma con un'aria di
sudiciume che sta benissimo in armonia
con quello del venditore cioè questa è
la definizione che da Carlo Lodi alla
fine dell'Ottocento appunto della pizza
napoletana una cosa sudicia Ma del resto
era davvero così quindi la pizza si è
molto evoluta e tutta la nostra storia è
quella di essere di essersi
profondamente voluta tutta la nostra
cucina Si è profondamente evoluta
Guardate io vengo da Mantova adesso ho
parlato male dei miei amici napoletani
Io intanto la pizza io la adoro come
penso tutti gli italiani e io vengo da
Mantova a Mantova il nostro piatto
particolare sono i tortelli di zucca
e la storia dei fratelli di zucca è
abbastanza ridicola perché in realtà
Mantova e Ferrara litigano nel nome di
Isabella d'Este perché Isabella d'Este
nasce a Ferrara poi sposa Francesco
Gonzaga diventa marchesa di Mantova e lo
dei Ferraresi dicono ha imparato a fare
i tortelli a Ferrara e poi portato alla
ricercamento Mantova in Mantovan dico No
hai parlato mentre poi mandato la
ricetta dei tortelli di zucca a Ferrara
Il problema è che all'epoca di Isabella
d'Este e la zucca non c'era Quindi
evidente che questa storia non c'entra
assolutamente nulla Isabella d'Este e
però la cosa che per me è importante è
che io ho tre figlie che hanno 18-22 e
23 anni e io sono sicuro che se tra una
cena a base di tortelli di zucca e una
cena a base di sushi sceglierebbero
sicuramente sushi quindi ci sarà sempre
una parte di consumatori
sensibili alla storia di Isabella d'Este
veri inventata non mi interessa
assolutamente nulla ci sarà sempre
questa parte però Guardate la nostra
cucina è contaminazione e che l'Italia
proprio sul sushi da ultimo paese fino a
20 anni fa era assolutamente sconosciuta
Oggi siamo i primi consumatori in Europa
per sushi e allora la cosa che mi viene
a dire forse perché no perché non
possiamo immaginare appunto le massime
provocazioni Perché non possiamo
immaginare che si possa mettere davvero
l'ananas nella pizza oppure appunto la
panna nella carbonara e guardate alza
questioni oggi noi siamo anche grandi
produttori c'è stato poco tempo fa una
polemica di farina di insetti e chissà
che appunto fra qualche anno gli
italiani non si lamentino perché non c'è
l'ananas nella pizza o perché non c'è un
insetto nel piatto Grazie
[Applauso]